welcome to this video FM la la la la la
i am from Nuremberg mm-hmm so from
Bavaria yeah let's see the good old
Dutch what is he doing here playing a
sideline somebody recently told me that
a six would be good in this position I
could hardly believe that but maybe
that's true a 6 e 65 completely not
developing that ok maybe maybe it's
possible let's see what happens in this
game c5 can you play c5 voice there are
some drawback i know i'm just going to
develop of course the drawback is that
for white is that the nitrous on c3 it
should be behind the porn so i have to
invest a bit of time to get see
foregoing the good news it that the
general structure this kind of stone
wall against III is kind of favorable
for white so I mean favorable not like
oh I'm winning but it's kind of ok
uh-huh so what is he doing trying to
quickly get it to age five maybe hmm
interesting yeah he never played c6 this
is an interesting little detail so that
taking on d6 looks kind of unattractive
most mostly ok I'm still going to play
this I mean Fosse form somehow I don't
really see how to play without c4
came it's upside let's take and then go
see for I want night f4 on Bishop h5
this is why I took on d6 first took with
the Queen mmhmm yeah maybe this is the
this is an option that's it's not not a
very common way to play this ok but
anyway hmm ok so c5 looks like looks a
nonsensical if I take it what does he
recaptured he takes Bishop f5 looks like
a pawn so he takes with this ok right 33
ok taking before him want to play Quincy
to maybe be five I think I can ok i was
i was i'm actually I saw this wrong I
thought I could could play with Bishop
c4 in this position but I cannot ok well
this was part of the idea anyway II 5b
5c four symbols maybe looks looks kind
of fishy this idea but maybe it's
possible hmm
I am maybe bishop yeah this is really
funny idea v5e FOIAs be takes c6 it's
not so great okay it wasn't the initial
idea but not not a problem really like
it's okay yeah I must have applied it
badly somehow really should have
preserved a little something but I did
not the 84 night xe3 and this kind of
moves they they look they look tricky
already night xe3 it's even coming after
quincy 20 moves like that hmm
huh don't I really have a great move
here maybe this for Queen deform at the
moment the night cannot move because of
d8 hanging I just I need to I need a
place for the Queen so I'm thinking
queen deform maybe he moves it away and
then queen bee to this this kind of
thing Queen d4 right there is no tactic
and anything know if he trades I'm
definitely okay I mean more than okay so
i expect a move like Queen back to e7 or
so hmm maybe I can take a seven would be
very cheeky I did not really look at
that I that idea at all but maybe I can
really take the pawn very computer ish
move taking the pawn him Jim I don't
like it
don't like it at all but what what else
is there Quincy five maybe is f for an
ear for now maybe that move I don't know
looks it looks fishy Queen g5 is a move
now now for discoveries yeah I have to
play that one which is not very welcome
but maybe I get in some beef eyeball get
the bishop away b5 now right I would
then ok p6 Queen d4 still in this in
this pin yeah it's quite quite awkward
night f4 is this even check made bishop
takes Bishop takes rook c7 maybe should
checks threatening
oops is 7 I wanted to go walk c7 but he
might have crazy moves like Bishop g2
txt is not working hmm okay so maybe
just keep them keep this pressure on a
little bit it wasn't the plan but he
doesn't have I mean it looks scary a bit
with this bishop but I don't don't see
any time morning particular problem
we have quindi 6cm this Bank back rank
is also a huge problem okay how do I do
that quenya I can if I can go back here
right this is the easiest and now
somewhere else rh3 actually h3 is good
for rook rook is the rook is a root
why is covering c8 now I have to be
aware of that rook c8 is a move you like
to play that [ __ ] don't want I mean you
don't should avoid it I mean that's what
I'm trying to say here trying to double
on the 7th could have taken a 7-foot
that would put up an easier
yes letting the clock run down maybe
they've had a decent position at one
point pretty sure about that
disconnected or I don't know it looks
like oops no I wanted to do ping
actually there is really disconnected
this is this is not a black for offense
in Tunisia this is a technical
disconnect nothing like disconnect
instead of resigning yeah from tricky
stuff tricky stuff I I was it wasn't it
wasn't really working out we're dead
well this looked nice actually I thought
here what should be quite okay but I
didn't play well a 3 here yeah and now
before I can go in five probably this
initial idea this looks kind of I don't
know it doesn't look good i believe
don't like it so i went with this and TM
yeah this night takes you three ideas
it's kind of annoying but i think i
found good moves here yeah this is
actually our computer stuff Bishop c4 he
and queen d foyer he went back and yeah
Quincy five once again the core move
this looks this looks very cheeky okay
it's actually a failing yeah there's
some justice and chest this Queen struck
didn't see that idea at all so I went
here and here maybe yeah I didn't see
this at all I can take now as the
stackable yeah I didn't recognize that
this is hanging and so he has to do this
and now neither for this is quite needy
ax he doesn't have really good a good
square to go to yeah he is getting hit
with f3 and it's very nice for what I
didn't see that I only saw the idea this
idea now that that it's a kind of an
awkward pin
and originally I wanted to take on here
but I was irritated by this crazy move I
saw that but why is it working ah nice
very nice move oh here I look at this I
didn't see that one computer move that's
very cute that's very nice white wins
the house now rook c8 made basically are
winning everything what a nice move I
can also give the check first and play
this but here he has this and wins okay
I didn't see that one of course but
Queenie 5 should keep something right
yes took and lay there and choking here
yeah okay I have something quicker maybe
I also saw this idea this is also quite
nice chances on idea to check trade
stuff check with an exchange also quite
easily winning but ok this is enough I
believe just just for the rook yeah it
was a decent game I mean I found some
good moves after it was kind of getting
shaky so i'm satisfied here thanks for
watching